[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله معكم محمد مزيمه
لنتابع معا ابرز اخبار الاسبوع الماضي
بايجاز وضمن ابرز الاحداث امر بترحيل
السفير الفرنسي في النيجر الجابون تشهد
انقلابا على الرئيس بونجو حضروا ارتداء
العباءه في مدارس فرنسا اضافه الى اخبار
اخرى لنتابعها معا
نبدا نشرتنا من ملف تطورات الانقلاب في
النيجر اذ قالت وزاره الخارجيه التابعه
للمجلس العسكري في النيجر انها الغت الصفه
الدبلوماسيه للسفير الفرنسي ولعائلته
واصدرت تعليمات للشرطه بترحيل السفير
الفرنسي وعائلته من البلاد ياتي هذا
الاعلان بعد اربعه ايام من انتهاء المهله
التي حددها المجلس العسكري الحاكم للسفير
الفرنسي للمغادره في سياق متصل احال مجلس
الوزراء في بوركينا فاسو التي تؤيد
الانقلاب في النيجر مشروعه قانون الى
البرلمان يجيز ارسال قوه عسكريه الى
النيجر ينضم الينا من نيام مراسل الجزيره
فضل عبد الرزاق يا مرحبا فضل
ما ابرز التطورات لديك
العام الجديد هو انصار المجلس العسكري
يحتشدون هنا امام القاعده العسكريه
الفرنسيه للمطالبه بالرحيل القوات
الفرنسيه من النيجر ووزير الداخليه المجلس
العسكري يصدر تعليمات لقوات الامن بترحيل
السفير الفرنسي من النيجر باعتباره شخصا
غير مرغوب فيه
وان
ونه وكذلك
صار المجلس العسكري
بفرنسا ان تغادر قواتها
شكرا جزيلا لك فضل عبد الرزاق من الانقلاب
في النيجر الى الانقلاب في الجابون حيث
تتسارع وتطورات بعد اعلان عسكريين سلائهم
على السلطه ووضعيه الرئيس علي بونجو قيد
الاقامه الجبريه بعد ساعات قليله من اعلان
لجنه الانتخابات فوزه بولايه رئاسيه ثالثه
في حين خرجت في الشوارع العاصمه ديبروفيل
مظاهرات مؤيده للانقلاب وقد ظهر بانجو في
تسجيل مصور من مقر اقامته الجبريه موجهه
رساله الى كل العالم والاصدقاء للتحرك ضد
من قاموا باعتقاله قبل ان يؤدي قائد الحرس
الجمهوري القسم رئيسا للمرحله الانتقاليه
في حين لقي الانقلاب تمديدا افريقيا
ودوليا واسعا رواد منصات التواصل تفاعلوا
مع انقلاب الجابون لنقرا لكم بعضها
التغريدات ونبدا مع عادل عبد الوهاب الذي
يقول انتهاء حقبه فرنسا الاستعماريه على
القاره السمراء الافريقيه اما جراين محمد
فيقول والدك كان رئيسا الجابون منذ
1967 وفي 2009 انت اصبحت رئيسا مكان والدك
هل هي بالتوريث يتساءل ويقول ولا تزال
تطمع لولايات اخرى يا رجل الى فلسطين حيث
تصاعدت عمليات المقاومه ضد الاحتلال فقد
قتل جندي اسرائيلي وجرح سبعه بينهم ضابط
في عمليه دهس غرب رام الله وتفجير عبوه
الناس فشرق نابلس بينما دهمت قوه الاحتلال
منزل عائله هي المشتبه به في تنفيذ عمليه
الدهس وفي القدس استشهد فتى برصاص
الاحتلال بزعمه تنفيذه عمليه الطعن اما في
نابلس فقد اصيب اكثر من 90 فلسطينيا خلال
التصدي لاقتحام المستوطنين بحمايه قوات
الاحتلال لما يعرف بقبر يوسف ينضم الينا
عماد ابو عواد وهو الباحث في الشان
الاسرائيلي ومدير مركزي القدس للدراسات
مرحبا سيد عماد مسند بوهات المحتمله بشان
سياسه تل ابيب تجاه عملياتي المقاومه
اسرائيل جربت كل الوسائل الممكنه لايقاف
العمليات الفلسطينيه قتلت اعتقلت اجتاحت
المدن وذهبت الى عمليات عسكريه كل ذلك لم
يؤدي الى ايقاف العمليات قامت برده فعل
وهي المزيد من الاستيطان المزيد من القوه
ضد الفلسطينيين وكل هذا ايضا ساهم بارتفاع
وتيره المقاومه الفلسطينيه لذلك اسرائيل
ضمن الحلول التكتيكيه حاليا لا تمتلك حلا
لما يحدث على الارض يمكنها ان توقف
العمليات في حاله واحده اذ ذهبت باتجاه
اتفاق سياسي واعطاء الفلسطينيين حقوقهم
على الاقل في الضفه الغربيه لكن حتى
اسرائيل لا تمتلك قياده بامكانها الذهاب
بهذا الاتجاه لذلك ستبقي اسرائيل اداره
الصراع هي سيده الموقف لكن ذلك سيؤدي الى
المزيد من المقاومه الفلسطينيه شكرا جزيلا
لك عماد ابو عواد رئيس حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه الليبيه عبد الحميد الدبيبه اقل
جزيره الخارجيه نجلاء المنقوش واحالها
للتحقيق بعد لقاء اجرته سرا مع وزير
الخارجيه الاسرائيلي اليكوهين في ايطاليا
وجهاز الامنيه الداخليه الليبي اعلن
ادراجها ضمن قائمه الممنوعين من السفر
وكانت الخارجيه الليبيه اكدت ان ما حدث في
روما هو لقاء عارض وغير رسمي وغير معد
مسبقا في حين ذكر بيان للخريجيات
الاسرائيليه ان اللقاء كان لبحث
امكانياتها التعاون واقامه علاقات متبادله
وكيفيه الحفاظ على التراث اليهودي في
ليبيا الكشف عن اللقاء اثار ردود فعل
عديده من بينها احتجاجات واسعه وغاضبه في
العاصمه الليبيه طرابلس في التعليق الاول
تجدون فيديو يشرح تفاصيل اكثر حول هذه
الردود وسط جدل واصوات رافضه وانقسامات في
الطبقه السياسيه فرنسا بدات في حظر ارتداء
الفتيات العداء في المدارس التي تديرها
الدوله بدعوى ان العلمانيه التي هي احدى
القيم الاساسيه لمدارس الجمهوريه تحضر
ارتداء اي رموز ذات دلاله دينيه ماكرون
دعا الى التعامل بحزم لمنع ارتداء العباءه
وغيرها مما وصفها بالملابس الاسلاميه في
المدارس قائلا ان الحكومه لن تتهاون في
فرض القرار في المقابل اعلن المجلس
الاسلامي الفرنسي عن استغرابه للقرار ونفى
ان يكون هذا الزي رمزا دينيا بينما
استنكرت شخصيات من اليسار الفرنسي هذه
الخطوه واعتبرتها حربا عبثيه على الدين
الاسلامي شاركونا اراءكم في التعليقات هل
قرار حظر العباءه في المدارس الفرنسيه
يناقض مبدا الحريه التي تنادي به الدوله
في انتظار تعليقاتكم نشكركم على متابعتي
ايجازنا لهذا الاسبوع نلتقي بحول الله
الاسبوع المقبل انما كنتم اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]